well basically
i wasn't in cell uh
when i was growing up i was the fat kid
i was like really really fat that was a
piece
and it took me all two years come over
it like ten years
moving from 50 body fat to
10 body fat and now basically my top 10
and getting used to it is
is weird because in the back of my mind
i'm still a loser i'm still black-peeled
yeah and it's do this transmission go to
the next level go to the next screen
to understand that i'm an alpha it's
like it's blown my mind every time
and i'm i have a better first and i'm
addicted to a lot of [ __ ]
and i'm going to therapy going to
internal family system ifs
how long does it take man doing the work
okay so because i
am doing the work and it never ends okay
so let's deal with that so right now
you're not getting laid
no i'm not getting old okay so how old
were you when you left
oh my god 21. okay and
how old are you now 42
okay and when was the last time you got
laid
man that turns
six months okay no big deal it's not too
too bad
i mean we've all had a six month try
spell it's not a big deal so what do you
think is stopping you from
being successful with women you know to
getting out of this rock bottom that
you're feeling
i'm very insecure about what man
approaching women talk to them handle
their it's the foreign
kid yeah and handling the failure every
time because
you just it's hard to accept it
it's this feeling of failures
so yeah hello let me tell you this bro
i'm gonna tell you this
right now if you do not fix this problem
of being scared to approach women
you're not gonna get laid i'm telling
you this right right now the the
99 of problems that guys have with
getting women comes down to networking
volume
the only way you're going to be able to
work volume at a
acceptable level where you can actually
take numbers from it and get laid
is by cold approaching and using online
dating and using other methodology
to source your problem is you're not
putting any leads in your funnel
which means if you don't have any leads
in your funnel you're not going to get
sex how many girls have you spoken to
today
today none okay because your risk averse
about that
go back to my mr nice guy series it'll
get you started for byron's advice
that's your problem like you got to
understand this me every single day i'm
talking to at least
10 to 20 girls easy whether it's through
online dating girls that i'm approaching
uh when i'm walking to the gym
whatever it may be you have a volume
problem you understand
like you need to we need to figure out
what your problem is and it is you 100
are not talking to enough women if you
don't talk to women
you're not going to get laid where do
you live man
i live in israel
i had to remove it by surgery yeah so
that's the point for 10 years you were
an insecure fat guy
you've been thin now i don't know how
long let's say a year you're thinking
you can
rewire 10 years of thinking like that
overnight it doesn't happen you
literally have to
oh man i wish i understand that the way
you used to think about things
is wrong your feelings are bad you
should feel bad let me ask some
questions here
so you are you jerking off and looking
at porn i feel like you are
duh
yeah that stifles your natural sexual
hunger and then that's going to get in
the way
you can you're going to become
complacent like oh i won't talk to girls
let me just jerk off and roll over and
go to bed
and you can get caught a cycle because i
i used to do that man
just go to fuckingampland.com go to town
but it [ __ ] messes with you it messes
with your ability
to to pull more girls in and you have to
keep that natural
natural sexual hunger and like rich was
saying too like when you go to the gym
and you exercise
it builds up your your your sexual
desire and like you know that you lets
you know your hormones are working okay
and um yeah man i could just see like
your nervous wreck too
do you work or your mom and dad pay for
everything what do you do
no uh i actually got fired because of
coronavirus
but i'm a cure engineer also now i'm
trying to get to
a automation developer
uh basically high tech right now
man
listen we'll work together you know like
focus like sometimes when we're talking
you talk over us
that shows me let's find your social
acuity like
pay attention to us because we're all
trying to help you so when was the last
time
you worked you got fired how far ago how
long ago
four months ago so you haven't why
haven't you gotten a job in four months
i mean
is it tough to get a job right now or uh
okay it's a senior position very tough
it's hard as a hard competition
i get second rate of most of the time
it's like me or this someone else and
they
usually pick up someone else so i still
unemployed
what if i don't get anything hey when
you're working like what do you usually
earn when you're working
in shackles or dollars
uh us dollars just kind of you know 6
10 it's like
between four to five thousand i guess a
month
yeah so i mean like you earn pretty
decent income when you're working
you're a little bit of a nervous wreck
as john pointed out
so you've got some approach anxiety for
sure like if you go to the bank for
example if you go to the teller right
okay so if you go to the teller and you
got a pretty girl behind the counter
what do you do normally
i usually don't approach you don't say
anything to her
i'm deeply scared
start start there because you're doing
business anyway like you're at the
counter you've put your card in the
machine
she's serving you just just find
something to talk about
that opens dialogue about anything just
anything
what anything literally the less
important the better are you trying to
intensify yourself to this what are you
up to this weekend
you know you're doing anything fun this
weekend you know
see if you know tv get crack start
talking
just start talking to women yeah you can
expand on that as well
by the way because when you're out and
about you could go out and just make a
point of speaking to
say five or ten people just just on the
course of the walk don't and
set the bar really low don't think i've
got to be impressive
don't think i've got to look cool in
front of her just be like hey how's
you having a nice day it's nice weather
today you look really nice or
you know or you don't even need to go
that far you could just try asking for
directions
you've just got to get yourself used to
talking to people and realizing that
and realizing that the world's not going
to collapse in on you and don't even try
to pull them don't try to get a phone
number don't try to do anything just
like see you later you know
nice to speak to you see you later walk
off just get the get the ball rolling
okay that's what you need to do it's
like john said earlier
you know the seducer needs to seduce the
world right so the way to start that
is to start communicating with people as
much as you possibly can and then the
anxiety will start to die down but
listen man
i mean you look pretty from what i can
see you look pretty good
you know you've got a good strong voice
you know you've clearly got some
you've clearly got some some stuff going
on for you you know you've got a good
you know professional background and
everything like that man so there's a
lot of good stuff here you know
like don't don't be like doing yourself
down just you know you just need to get
the ball rolling you need to get the
momentum going
have you have you gotten into anything
physical lately i mean you go to a gym
you go to a dojo like what do you do for
self-care i work out at least three
times a week
it used to be five times a week okay
well you're in israel do you know how to
do krav maga
uh a bit krav maga
kickboxing do you do it on a regular
basis are you a member of a dojo
uh not right now just james uh
just a workout routine abc
so what are you doing you're just
sitting around all day thinking and
feeling sorry for yourself
no i'm right now very very looking
hard working on looking for a new job
my work is find a new work right
and i go to three interviews a week but
it's a
very tough competition
okay so um i don't know
but listen um i would just say yeah put
every
all your concentration into getting
employed as soon as possible because
and and don't go down are you going down
like youtube rabbit holes and like
watching a bunch like
dark black pill content [ __ ] like that
i used to i stopped this [ __ ]
yeah that's not going to help i mean if
you go looking for negative
reinforcement
reminding you easily find it you're
looking for negative you found negative
yeah um let me ask you about this uh i'm
sorry
your name is pronounced eliran is that
am i right yes
i don't want to mispronounce you now uh
do you have like social circles do you
have friends that you hang out with
do you have like real live in real time
like a tribe that you hang out with
like of guys are you okay with like
interacting with toddler guys as well
like are you like more introverted or
are you just like staying at home like
watching us and then on on forums or
whatever do you have any like real
friends that you hang out with
i have but most of them are already
married with children
and i'm just uh
not with them anymore i'm actually very
far away from most of my friends
i live in the center of israel most of
them live in the
shawn area are you in a big city
yes television
yeah there is okay i mean there's lots
of women there for sure then so there's
no shortage of opportunities it's just
you need to capitalize them here's
here's what i'm going to recommend that
you do so we can move on because i got a
bunch of other guys waiting there and i
got a bunch of super shots one
there's a book called psycho cybernetics
by maxwell maltz have you read it
no read it okay okay
it's in my um amazon bookstore or
audiobook
i don't know probably uh i'm sure it is
it's called psycho cybernetics
and the author is maxwell maltz so read
that book one two
get your ass into combat sports right so
you can feel a lot more confident about
um you know situations when you approach
them
there's just something that changes when
you know that you can really f somebody
up
when you just kind of go about life so
get into that second thing
your third thing is just get yourself a
job and then finally
as you're as you're going about life as
you get your groceries as you get a
coffee as you're at the bank at the
teller
whenever you see a girl chat her up
beyond just the basic business
conversation of
i'm here to deposit a check yes sir
open up with something hey the weather
is great what are you up to this weekend
just something or what's in your coffee
enrichment
and go and the other thing too bro after
we you get off the stream go and talk to
five girls
just do it okay
all right man thanks okay thank you guys
you